alle freuen sich jetzt auf den sommer in
berlin und wisst ihr wer sich am meisten
darauf freut die große koalition merkel
sparen und scholz alle hoffen sie auf
ein sommermärchen
ja geht den leuten urlaub sonne tralala
impfen und reisen und schon ist alles
vergeben und vergessen echt wahr wir
werden in der politischen debatte und
auch in der medialen debatte nach dieser
corona lage alle miteinander viel
verzeihen müssen okay was sie aber auf
keinen fall vergessen sollten sind die
gewaltigen defizite die korona brutal
offengelegt hat diese überbordende
bürokratie die wir zum beispiel bei den
im priorisierungen gesehen haben die
impfzentren lahm legen unsere völlige
unfähigkeit einfach mal zu kopieren und
pragmatisch zu sein und lösungen
abzuschauen die andere schon vor uns
gefunden haben und dann die
digitalisierung wo wir irgendwie
feststellen dass wir wahrscheinlich den
90ern stehen geblieben sind und diese
zukunft vergessenheit dieses leben auf
kosten von unseren kindern das sieht man
zum beispiel besonders bei der bildung
[Musik]
mein name ist thomas reichert ich bin
korrespondent im zdf hauptstadtstudio
und ich verrate euch warum vergeben und
vergessen in sachen krone überhaupt
keine gute idee ist und die hoffnung auf
ein sommermärchen
schon gar nicht ich verrate euch jetzt
was ich bekomme langsam schiss vor
diesem sommer sommer laufen in der
berliner politik nicht gut im letzten
jahr ist die infektionszahlen runter
gegen fallen die ich zwischen reichstag
und kanzleramt kaum ein politiker mehr
denn über corona gesprochen hätte das
war irgendwie weg und dann kam die
zweite und dritte welle mit ansage aber
wir waren halt nicht darauf vorbereitet
die gleichen fehler drohen wir jetzt
wieder zu machen wir lernen einfach
nicht aus unseren fehlern und diesmal
ist es besonders gravierend denn diesmal
geht es um unsere zukunft nach corinna
[Musik]
es gibt in dieser pandemie einen
auffallenden gegensatz zwischen dem was
bund und länder von uns bürgern
verlangen strengen regeln und dem nur
sie selbst hinkriegen der impf gipfel
ende april ist dafür ein prima beispiel
erst mal dauerte es ewig bis es
überhaupt einen termin für diesen gipfel
gab
solange das offenbart
ministerpräsidentinnen sich schon fragen
sms schicken
hast du was gehört wann es losgeht
das in der korona pandemie der gipfel
sollte eigentlich klären welche
freiheiten geimpfte und genesene zurück
bekommen sollen die sind ja nicht mehr
ansteckend und deswegen kein risiko mehr
aber das sind ja auch fragen die jetzt
nicht völlig neu sind man die kollegin
christiane hübscher darüber schon vor
langem ein tolles inside politik gemacht
das könnt ihr euch hier anschauen
ich habe den eindruck es passieren immer
wieder die gleichen fehler
bund und länder gehen mit den
entscheidenden fragen zu spät zu langsam
und völlig unvorbereitet und am ende hab
dabei leider auch viel murks heraus dass
genesene und geimpfte wieder mehr
freiheiten bekommen
das fanden einige schon per se eine
blöde idee und hat man es vielleicht
deswegen überhaupt nicht eilig damit ich
halte gar nichts davon zu sagen wie mit
einem windhundrennen dass die die jetzt
nun das glück haben zuerst geübt worden
zu sein dass die dann auch wirklich
wieder dinge in anspruch nehmen können
und andere nicht
wichtig ist dass wir
im augenblick nicht doppelte privilegien
wollen
ich habe das privileg schon geimpft zu
sein und dann habe ich noch mehr
privilegien wie
hauptstadtkorrespondenten stellen uns
bei solchen gipfel immer auf viel wasser
rein aber diesmal ging das alles total
schnell wir kamen nicht einmal dazu
tetris zu spielen warum weil sie gar
nichts entschieden haben
dieser gipfel beim grund ein stuhlkreis
wo man gut mal darüber geredet hat aber
eben nichts entschieden es ist eine mpk
der enttäuschten hoffnung oder eine mpk
der mutlosigkeit die wir da wieder
erlebt haben und insgesamt kann man
sicherlich sagen es fehlt so eine
gewisse fehlerkultur ist stattdessen
erleben wir tatsächlich vieles doch in
wiederholung in einer gewissen
endlosschleife okay die lockerungen für
geimpfte und genesene kamen dann doch
einfach mal
der druck war einfach zu groß aber was
das alles konkret bedeutet da gibt es
noch viele fragezeichen bund und länder
lernen einfach nicht aus dieser krise zb
ist noch völlig offen wie genesenen
nachweisen können dass sie genesen sind
hätte man eigentlich schon längst klären
müssen aber ist nicht passiert und das
nervt offenbar sogar hamburgs ersten
bürgermeister peter tschentscher der
kritisiert ich lese euch das mal vor
dass wir noch keinen nachweis über den
status als genesene person haben der
durch ein einfaches dokument regelt wann
beginnt und endet dieser genesenen
status und wie kann dieser zeitraum
überhaupt kontrolliert werden
es ist sagt tschentscher an der stelle
nicht gut vorgearbeitet worden und man
kann peter tschentscher nur recht geben
aber lieber tschentscher sie haben ja
offenbar auch nicht gut vorgearbeitet
nicht klar
[Musik]
aber sind wir mal ein bisschen
optimistisch schauen wir in die zukunft
hoffnungsfroh und stellen uns vor wir
sind alle zweifach geimpft
und dann muss die freiheit immer noch
warten
und das liegt woran weil wir die
digitalisierung verpennt haben auch das
mit ansage
das problem ist dass gelbe heftchen wir
haben das mal dem griechischen tourismus
minister gezeigt wer nicht schlecht so
im griechenland urlaub oder der minister
hat sich das heftchen angeguckt und
musste ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen das
lachen unterdrücken er will kann
zwischen complications of the dead
physik also die griechen kriegen das
sind ideen die auch egal wichtig ist wie
kriegen sie nicht hin weil wir müssen
alles wieder selber finden wir müssen
lange plan und wir können auch nicht
einfach von anderen abschauen wie die es
machen wäre ja auch eine möglichkeit
doch immer so lange dauert sind wie
gesagt die technischen folge haben die
europäischen abstimmung wobei es gibt
einen landkreis in deutschland die hans
tatsächlich probiert und haben es
hingekriegt im januar schon landkreis
altötting der landrat fand ein digitaler
infos weiß ist eine gute sache und hat
es einfach mal probiert und es hat
geklappt daten sicher sogar entscheiden
diese im prinzip nicht immer wie lange
etwas dauert sondern dass man
rechtzeitig beginnt das heißt also man
muss natürlich zu erkenntnis kommen das
ist notwendig und zu dieser erkenntnis
sind wir schon im oktober letzten jahres
gekommen
der wurde bei uns noch darüber
diskutiert oder in deutschland darüber
diskutiert ob überhaupt genug leute
zunehmend zu gehen wochen später in
berlin hat da immer noch niemanden
interessiert die wollten ihr ahnt es
schon ihre eigene lösung in der
bundespressekonferenz hat eine
sprecherin des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums dann
erklärt in zehn tagen so ungefähr werde
man mit einem industriekonsortium
vielleicht zu einem abschluss kommen
ich ihnen sagen kann ist dass das bmg
beabsichtigt die mpu wirkstoffen digital
und bechtle also insgesamt vier
unternehmen mit der entwicklung einer
impfpass app zu beauftragen die
stillhaltefrist bis zum
vertragsabschluss beträgt noch zehn tage
seitdem sind wieder wochen vergangen der
digitale impfausweise ist immer noch
nicht da und das was ich zuletzt jetzt
aus dem bundesgesundheitsministerium
erfahren habe ist dass man sich in einem
dynamischen entwicklungsprozess befinde
dynamisch klingt vielversprechend oder
mich erinnert das ganze an das drama um
die korona waren app oder an die frage
ob masken gegen das virus helfen da war
sich minister sparen am anfang auch
nicht so sicher hat lange gedauert und
wird vermutlich auch jetzt wieder lange
dauern es ist ja genau die alte misere
wir lernen nichts aus unseren fehlern
aber wir sollen ja vergeben wir werden
in der politischen debatte alle
miteinander viel verzeihen müssen wenn
es dann irgendwann diesen digitalen
impfausweise wirklich gibt dann werden
alle die bis dahin geimpft wurden also
ein paar millionen mit ihrem gelben im
vergleich zu dem zentrum oder zum
hausarzt rennen um sie das übertragen zu
lassen mit ihnen wir sind ja im
digitalen palio 10 all jene die das
ausgenutzt haben und in gelben in fonds
weiß gefälscht haben wie erlebt ihr
gerade dieses impfchaos schreibt mir
darüber ich bin gespannt auf eure
geschichten und das was ihr so erlebt
[Musik]
apropos digitalisierung ich wollte mal
wieder nachschauen wie weit die mit der
digitalisierung der schulen dran sind
ist mir eine herzensangelegenheit ich
habe zwei söhne die seit monaten im
distanz unterricht sind und das war
sicher lebe ist das distanz unterricht
bedeutet viel distanz und fast gar kein
unterricht also habe ich mal wieder
nachgefragt beim bundesministerium für
bildung und forschung und die haben mir
geschrieben dass von den rund 6,5
milliarden euro die in digital pakt für
die schulen bereit stehen nach zwei
jahren rund 488 millionen euro
abgeflossen sind das sind 75 prozent in
zwei jahren wahnsinn oder
das ist wirklich zum verzweifeln das
bedeutet dass unsere kinder auf die
digitalisierung ihrer klassenzimmer
wahrscheinlich noch viel länger warten
müssen als auf ihre erste impfung
kinder und jugendliche sind bei uns
einfach immer zuletzt dran das ist nicht
überall so das muss auch nicht so sein
aber es ist eben bei uns so und es ist
wieder einer dieser fehler die es seit
beginn der korona pandemie gibt die
jeder beklagt und bei der bund und
länder ständig versprechen dass sie es
besser machen werden passiert nur leider
nicht
[Musik]
und während wir das alles nicht
hinkriegen ändert sich um uns herum die
welt fundamental kriegen wir vielleicht
nicht mit weil wir auf all die
komplizierten chor ohne regeln schauen
aber es wird eine neue weltordnung nach
corona geben mit einem machtbewussten
china das die regeln der welten neu
schreibt und mit den usa die gerade
dabei sind mit vielen billionen dollar
irland neu zu erfinden mit gewaltigen
infrastruktur massen haben mit einem
digitalisierungs und mit einem tempo von
dem wir bislang nur träumen konnten
alles dinge die auch bei uns gut sein
sollten
alles dinge die auch wir gut machen
könnten die wir gut gebrauchen könnten
alles dinge die längst hätten passieren
müssen aber wir hierzulande stecken den
kopf in den sand tun so als könnten wir
weitermachen wie bisher nichts gelernt
wir hatten das schon oder nun also ein
beispiel die deutsch-chinesischen
regierungskonsultationen finden alle
zwei jahre statt ist tradition routine
und auch diesmal war es genau so können
wir anfangen fragt chinas
ministerpräsident sehr gerne sie sind
jung sie sind ja gastgeber höher machen
sie mal alles wie immer alles so als
wäre ich ihn noch nicht dabei sein
herrschaftsanspruch im inneren wie im
äußeren mit aller macht durchzudrücken
und alle platt zu machen die sich
dagegen stellen aber wir tun so als wäre
alles wie immer weil wir darauf hoffen
dass china uns aus der wirtschaftlichen
krise heraus hilft mit seinen riesigen
markt brauchen wir halten
[Musik]
in chinesischen heißt krise welche das
sind zwei worte rey steht für gefahr
für chance wahnsinn oder krise so zu
begreifen als chance als möglichkeit was
neues zu machen nicht so wie wir uns wo
man immer die gleichen fehler noch mal
nacht und am ende auf ein sommermärchen
hofft auf eine wunde hafte rettung von
den eigenen versäumnissen
wie seht ihr das handy da gerade eine
chance schreibt mir ich bin wirklich
gespannt auf eure sicht und antwort ja
auch darauf und freue mich wenn ihr das
nächste mal wieder dabei sein bei inside
politics unseren blick hinter die
kulissen der berliner politik